bienvenido al vídeo del teorema de
taylor y de los polinomios de taylor
bueno de hecho ya estuvimos hablando un
poco de esto antes cuando hicimos los
vídeos de aproximar funciones con
polinomios nos encontramos con la serie
de mavi loring que como comentamos es un
caso particular del teorema de taylor lo
que hicimos en ese entonces fue
aproximar la función a alrededor de x
igual a 0 pero en general podríamos
aproximar una función alrededor de
cualquier valor y cuando lo hacemos
alrededor de algo que no sea 0 entonces
tenemos algo más general y ya estamos
hablando del teorema de taylor entonces
pues qué es esto del teorema de taylor y
de los polinomios de taylor para lo que
voy a hacer es comenzar anunciando el
teorema después voy a dar un ejemplo
para que fijemos las ideas al final voy
a hacer una gráfica para que entendamos
que está sucediendo empezamos con una
función diferenciable efe de x y lo que
quiero hacer es aproximar la aproximar
la con un polinomio ence en un punto c
es decir donde x vale c ahí quiero dar
un polinomio que se parezca mucho a la
función déjame hacer un pequeño dibujo
así muy esbozado y después hacemos algo
más padre supongamos que ahí tenemos el
plano aquí
y ahí tenemos nuestra función f de x y
además de esto tomamos un valor se
digamos como por aquí a ver lo voy a
poner aquí este es el punto c lo que
queremos lograr es proponer un polinomio
que se aproxime a efe alrededor de este
punto c lo que nos dice el teorema de
taylor es justamente como es este
polinomio voy a escribir el polinomio de
taylor y luego hablamos de por qué
funciona a ver el polinomio es vamos a
llamarle p entonces px está un poco
complicado pero ahorita con los ejemplos
se va a aclarar
pd x es igual a y entonces dice f de c y
luego más f prima de c
x x c
más efe doble prima de c dividido entre
aquí le voy a poner un 2 factorial pero
si quieres ver que vamos con un mismo
patrón puedes pensar que aquí arriba hay
un entre 1 factorial y que aquí hay un
entre 0 factorial va entonces luego es
esto por x menos c al cuadrado
más ya se está acabando el espacio
efe triple prima aquí podría poner un 3
pero lo voy a poner los primas ahorita
evaluada en c entre 3 factorial x x c al
jugo y podríamos seguir sumando y
sumando términos hasta infinito bueno
quiero explicarte la intuición que hay
detrás de este polinomio pero antes
déjame poner un sumando más para dejar
bien claro el patrón entonces nos
quedaría más
efe aquí voy a poner 4 es decir la
cuarta derivada de la función evaluada
en c dividido entre 4 factorial x x
menos a la cuarta y bueno ahora sí
pasemos a la intuición bueno veamos qué
sucede con este polinomio cuando
evaluamos en c quien es p de c va pues
para determinar psc tenemos que ir aquí
arriba la definición de p y sustituir
cada x por c entonces esté sumando aquí
nos queda se menos entonces se hace 0 en
este de acá también tenemos menos c
entonces a 0 aquí una vez más nos queda
0 y en este también nos queda ser menos
que cero y lo único que nos queda es un
fcc fcc sale eso es muy bueno lo que nos
dice es que p evaluado en c tiene el
mismo valor que f de este modo el
polinomio pasa por este punto de hecho
si tuviéramos un polinomio de taylor
solo con el primer sumando entonces en
la gráfica se vería como una línea
horizontal más o menos así pasa por el
punto pero es una mala aproximación
ahora que hace este segundo término
hasta ahora nada pues todo se canceló
lo que yo afirmo es que este segundo
término se asegura de que la derivada de
este polinomio y la derivada de la
función
efe coinciden en el punto c vamos a ver
a qué me refiero para esto
derivamos el polinomio es decir
encontramos pp prima de x prima de x eso
es igual a pues a ver aquí tenemos una
constante aquí la f es una función pero
ya evaluada en un número entonces es una
constante que tiene derivada 0 ahora
cuál es la derivada de este término pues
a ver la derivada de bueno esta prima de
s es constante ya que hay
x sé que tiene una derivada 1 entonces
podemos pensarlo como la constante por
equis y cuando derivamos nos queda f
prima de c x 1 entonces simplemente nos
queda f prima de c vamos al tercer
sumando más la derivada de esta
expresión a ver aquí tenemos 1 2 x 1 / 2
factorial que es un 1 y entonces nada
más nos queda
efe doble prima de c x x men o sea la
pues a la 1 le dejamos así más haberes 3
entre 3 factorial que es un medio
entonces nos queda nos queda efe
triple prima evaluado en c dividido
entre dijimos 2 verdad y luego x x menos
al cuadrado y podríamos seguir sumando y
sumando términos no nos debe importar lo
demás lo que te quiero mostrar es qué
sucede cuando evaluamos peppers y men se
deprima en c va que sucede cuando
sustituimos x 11 en toda esta expresión
bueno cuando ponemos x es igual a c
entonces el segundo sumando el t
y todos los de adelante se cancelan y
solo nos queda este de aquí aquí tenemos
un c c
es 0 x la doble deriva de 0 y lo mismo
pasa con el tercer término se cancela
entonces lo único que nos queda es f
prima de c eso lo que nos dice es que
prima desee simplemente f prima evaluado
en c super entonces que está sucediendo
lo que hace el polinomio de taylor es
número uno que cuando lo evaluarse en x
iguala se tiene el mismo valor que f es
decir pdc es igual a fcc en la derivada
también de prima de c es igual a efe
prima de c lo mismo va a pasar con la
segunda derivada con la tercera derivada
y pues con todas las derivadas de hecho
cada uno de los humanos está encargado
de que eso suceda
de hecho el sumando n uno se encarga de
que funcione la enésima derivada bueno
la gran idea detrás de esto y en lo cual
se nota la genialidad de taylor es la
observación de que si tenemos una
función f y suponemos que es
infinitamente diferenciable es decir que
existe la primera segunda tercera y así
sucesivamente derivada
entonces podemos construir un polinomio
como el que escribí aquí abajo fijan
digamos este de acá claro sumando más y
más términos de modo que esté polinomio
aproxime viena efe con esto nos
referimos a que todas las derivadas de
este polinomio coinciden con las
derivadas de f es decir con la primera
con la segunda con la tercera todas
éstas coinciden con la de f alrededor
del punto c de hecho más aún después
veremos que hay muchas funciones que su
polinomio de taylor con todos los
sumandos no sólo aproximan a la función
en sí sino que son igual a la función en
todos los puntos hablamos un poco de
esto cuando probamos que el api podría
es igual a menos 1 verdad que por cierto
para mí es el resultado más
impresionante de las matemáticas pero
que creo que me estoy yendo por la
tangente para que no quede tan confuso
esto hagamos un ejemplo detalladamente
dicen por ahí que el [ __ ] está en los
detalles
bueno aquí no de hecho espero que todo
nos quede más claro voy a borrar no con
amarillo no a ver voy a borrar aquí con
negro entonces voy a borrar estos
términos de acá voy a borrar la gráfica
de la
ya dijimos que después vamos a hacer una
más padre
ok y entonces vamos a aproximar coseno
de x entonces supongamos que fx lo voy a
poner con otro color que fx es igual a
coseno de x este rosa mexicano me gusta
mucho vamos a tomar un número arbitrario
digamos pues no sea alrededor del punto
c igualados no no nos mejor uno sale
entonces vamos a aproximar coseno de x
alrededor de c igual a 1 vámonos a la
fórmula a ver entonces vamos a ver el
polinomio de taylor a ver vamos a
escribirlo por aquí vamos a hacerlo así
como que muy sobre la marcha vale no voy
a hacer muy detallado entonces p de x es
igual a efe de c a ver entonces la
función evaluada en c
es simplemente coseno de 1 luego tenemos
que sumar la derivada de f evaluada en c
acá en la definición de f vemos que es
coseno y por tanto su derivada es menos
seno de equis verdad menos seno de xy
tenemos que evaluarla en uno entonces es
menos
seno de uno va es igual a uno todavía
nos falta multiplicar por algo verdad o
multiplicar por equis y luego haber
tenemos que sumar la segunda derivada
habéis vámonos a efe su primer derivada
es menos seno y la derivada de menos
menos coseno entonces nos queda menos
jose no evaluado en el punto cc es 1
entonces nos queda menos coseno de 1
jose no de una verdad dividido entre dos
factorial bueno todos lo dejamos así
y ahora hay que multiplicar por x menos
1 elevado al cuadrado perdón este se
debió haber sido un uno va se es igual a
uno verdad entonces no tiene caso
ponerle c mejor le ponemos 1 ok ahora
vamos con el cuarto sumando a ver es la
derivada de menos coseno de x la
derivada de cose no es menos seno pero
con el menos se hace más seno entonces
más
evaluado en el punto c otra vez en 1
ahora dividido entre 3 factorial que es
6 dividido entre 6 y luego x x 3 elevado
al kubán no jefe en verdad no no no
perdón déjame déjame deshacer esto a ver
aquí no va a un 3 sino un 1 a lo mejor
sí es cierto eso de que el [ __ ] está
en los detalles bueno en fin sigamos
hagamos un término más entonces nos
queda la cuarta derivada es decir la
derivada de la tercera derivada y la
tercera derivada en seno entonces ahora
nos debe de quedar más coseno de x
evaluado entre igual a 1 es decir coseno
de 1 dividido entre 4 factorial 4
factoriales 3 factorial o sea 6 x 4
entonces da 24 luego x x menos uno
elevado a la cuarta y podríamos seguir y
seguir haciendo la quinta sexta séptima
derivadas evaluarlas en uno dividir
entre el factorial multiplicar por x men
o sea el exponente correspondiente en
fin muchísima diversión pero vamos a
dejarle aquí en vez de eso vamos a ver
cómo se ve la gráfica conforme sumamos y
sumamos términos
déjame saco mi programa super pro para
hacer gráficas mira es este de aquí para
dar un poco de crédito este programa lo
saqué de m&a punto hr w puntocom aquí en
rojo puse la gráfica de coseno de x
junto a esta gráfica lo primero que haré
es poner simplemente coseno de 1 es
decir el primer sumando del polinomio lo
voy a escribir aquí arriba en mi
programa
entonces coseno de un 1 y ahora aquí le
tengo que picar en graficar esta mira
tenemos una línea horizontal
simplemente nos queda una línea
horizontal porque todos estos términos
se cancelaron y entonces sólo nos queda
una constante es una muy mala
aproximación pero al menos es igual a la
función en este punto en el 1,2 en o de
1 algo es algo verdad vamos a sumar el
segundo término a ver qué pasa
el segundo es menos seno de 1 x x menos
vamos a ponerlo entonces lo voy a
escribir aquí arriba menos seno d
x x menos 1
ah no perdón pero x menos uno está
graficar
mira eso está mejor ahora que sucede
pues esto de aquí ya está más padre
cuando ponemos dos términos nos queda
una recta que no solo pasa por el punto
uno como a cociendo de uno sino que
además tiene la misma pendiente en ese
punto es decir la recta tiene la misma
pendiente que coseno de x en x es igual
a 1 eso de ahí está mejor ya es una
aproximación un poco pues un poco más
parecida verdad bueno esto de aquí
todavía no es como que muy muy muy buena
aproximación nada más es una
aproximación digamos decente por este
lado es una aproximación muy mal la
verdad vamos a sumar más términos a ver
qué sucede entonces mira aquí estoy
escribiendo los términos y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es escribir el siguiente
sumando entonces déjame verlo a ver por
aquí nos queda es menos coseno de uno
entre dos a ver lo voy a escribir en el
programa es menos coseno de 1
dividido entre dos y luego eso de ahí x
x menos 1 elevado al cuadrado va
graficar ahí está mira aquí escribí eso
aquí escribir la expresión y nos quedó
esta gráfica nos quedó una parábola mira
esto de aquí está todavía más padre que
en el caso anterior al principio tenemos
una línea horizontal que cruzaba en uno
como coseno de uno era algo pero estaba
muy chafa con el segundo sumando nos
aseguramos que la primera derivada
también coincidiera así la aproximación
tenía la misma pendiente que f ahora el
tercer término se asegura de que la
segunda derivada del polinomio en x
igual a 1 también coincide con la
segunda derivada de la función f
geométricamente lo podemos comprobar
checando digamos la convexidad mira el
polinomio de aquí es cóncavo y cerca de
1 la función coseno de x también es
cóncava entonces eso nos da pues más o
menos una señal de que la segunda
derivada de lo mismo
vale entonces eso está padre cada vez se
parece más y más la aproximación por
ejemplo por aquí ya está aproximado
mejor antes aquí a la izquierda la
función se separaba de efe pero ahora
las gráficas ya están más juntas esto se
está poniendo emocionante vamos a añadir
un término más aquí está entonces nos
queda más
seno de uno dividido entre 6 x x menos
uno elevado al cubo graficar a esta
mirada esa ley es la expresión y le voy
a poner aquí que la gráfica
enter
orale guau esto de aquí está mucho mejor
verdad con tan solo tres términos en
nuestro polinomio bueno no en realidad
con cuatro verdad este de aquí es el
cuarto sumando el de la tercera derivada
es el cuarto sumando bueno se entiende
el punto estamos empezando a aproximar
la función bastante bien ahora la
tercera derivada del polinomio también
coincide con la tercera derivada de la
función f en el punto x es igual a 1 sin
la interpretación geométrica te la debo
sería algo así como la concavidad de la
derivada bueno como sea lo que notamos
es que la función que dan mejor
aproximada bueno siempre y cuando no nos
vayamos mucho a los extremos ya que ahí
sí es muy diferente pero vaya si sólo
hubiéramos de aquí aquí sería difícil
distinguir entre una y otra vamos a
poner el último término que calculamos
después de eso debería de quedarnos más
padre entonces el último término es más
coseno de uno dividido entre 24 si te
das cuenta conforme vamos sumando
términos están acompañados por un factor
distinto uno un medio un sexto uno entre
cada vez causan menos impacto realmente
solo empiezan a importar si nos alejamos
mucho mucho de la sede elegida en este
caso sea igual a 1 cuando estamos cerca
de 1 en realidad estos términos los de
la derecha no nos importan mucho pues
son muy pequeños
el siguiente término tendría un 1 entre
5 factorial que es aún más pequeño y así
sucesivamente sin embargo si aquí se
aleja mucho de uno entonces estos
términos comienzan a ser más
significativos como x menos 1 ya es
grande entonces este término ya comienza
a jugar su papel en la aproximación
vamos a la gráfica a ver entonces debo
escribir aquí más coseno de 1 dividido
entre 24 x x menos 1 elevado a la cuarta
a ver qué nos queda le voy a aplicar
aquí graficar
y deja te enseño en la gráfica mira
todavía mejor y si tuvieras un poquito
más de tiempo libre podrías seguir
intentando sumar términos y sumar
términos y así bueno este es uno de los
vídeos más largos que he hecho hablamos
un poco de los polinomios de taylor y
esto puede ser un poco confuso porque
tiene efe sitges y muchas derivadas y
factoriales pero es bastante más
sencillo si pensamos la idea que está
detrás lo único que nos está diciendo el
teorema de taylor es que podemos
construir un polinomio que en algún
punto c que nosotros elijamos coincide
con la función f y más aún coincide en
todas sus derivadas en la primera en la
segunda en la tercera en la que queramos
pues de hecho si siguiéramos haciendo
más y más derivadas digamos la décima o
la onceava estos dos se van a parecer
muchísimo espero que este vídeo no te
haya confundido el teorema de taylor es
un tema muy difícil la pura fórmula es
espantosa la primera vez que uno la ve
espero que ahora puedas verla con un
poco más de intuición pero si no fue así
mejor olvida todo lo que dije